shut the scene what's the atmosphere
like there at the airport
oh dude Rousey Pats fans just talking
about Tommy's domination and the fact
that they knew all along
there was no keeping him down even
though Wahlberg left ooh sorry yeah I
removed by Mack yeah yeah people are
people are dazed confused in please I
what was the mood like where you were
when it was 28 3 it was fairly bleak I
mean I've seen this team they're
extremely hard to kill and I said that
it was starting to get dicey in my
immediate area in lo two of the press
box next to me was my guy still Perry
who also works to see if anyone kind of
started to look at each other wide eyes
because you don't like to get the game
completely raw it's just not good for
business so I didn't think that the gig
was up but it looked pretty bleak what I
didn't think at halftime at when it was
21 nothin 21 3 and I got 228 3 the only
sliver of hope that I mentioned was
maybe that a number of players that no
angle did run and dated in part by a
pick 6 would wear down the Atlanta
Falcons he said because they were fast
and they was flying around but they were
on the field a long time in a gym that
started to get pretty hot Dan who
deserved the MVP your MVP it's just of
what I don't understand like this is a
conversation with Tom Brady I mean James
White Jimmy White I gave it to everybody
earlier the week that James White would
be the x-factor but he's not reading the
defense he's not getting the team in an
out of place he's not delivering the
football on the face of task rush he's
putting his hands out he's catching it
he's running with it
Brady threw 63 times he completed 42 we
had to manage the clock manage the play
calls it's just you can't do that you
can't do it Danny trying to do it no I
just I wanted to know I didn't know you
were going to get that sensitive about
it but now I'm glad I asked
now it's in swimming I mean hashtag
Tommy dispersed everything that's more
well I thought white was great when you
have three touchdowns and 14 receptions
and you have the game-winner and a
two-point conversion at least you're in
the conversation I think there's a
conversation here but it was going to be
Brady if they won given what he did in
the second half and the fourth quarter
then and overtime Brady was going to get
it I understand that but I I think would
be a disservice to James white to not at
least address what he did last night and
put him in the conversation it's like
Malcolm Butler who was more valuable in
the previous super more valuable Malcolm
Butler Tom Brady you can at least put
Rutte Butler in the conversation because
he made the greatest single play in
Super Bowl history
yes definitions of value we could say
that thing can also say that if you had
you know Matt Schaub quarterbacking that
night then they wouldn't have been in
that spot to have Malcolm Butler make
that play he said Tom Curren Comcast
SportsNet New England joining a stand
Patrick show most valuable play last
night was turned in by who wow that's a
great one because there's some sneaky
ones in there there's a fourth down
completion by Brady after the ridiculous
double pass which was a big one and
there was also on a third and eight the
15-yard scramble by Brady's at that time
I believe it was still 28 to 3 might
have been 28 to 9 those were two huge
plays that are lost in the shuffle but
the drive starters to in the I mean
Edelman's catch this there's a suite of
them I actually was just watching them
again here at the year for them the NFL
Network and there were so many plays
that fit fit the description of you
weren't going to win without it and
that's because they had gotten
themselves to a margin of error that was
zero it was there was nothing else they
could do wrong you know what you know
what the biggest play was the high
collar strip shot without that in there
not getting the short field in ox court
so the high power strip sack was the one
team that felt more dead Patriots last
night Oh for Red Sox against the
Oh for Red Sox because it wasn't it
wasn't something that we had seen them
do before you know just a year before
they choked on her own vomit so you know
three so this we've seen what Brady came
back from 24 nothing down against Denver
on a Sunday night or Monday night a few
years ago he almost brought the team
back against San Francisco in 2012 in
San Francisco was good even when they
lost Philadelphia last year they were
down at the 35 14 that came whipping
back in a very short period of time they
did it you know with Seattle the only
thing I had a feeling was going to get
close but with the Red Sox you know Oh
for the party was over I mean that not
only did they have to get the stolen
base to get Dave Roberts into scoring
position and then get a single they had
to do that for two more nights so this
one was more probable than me not tech
another the other one would you like to
get the written transcripts of what
Goodell was saying to Tom Brady
I would I would know would it be also be
interested to hear what Brady was saying
back yeah you know like I was at the
back of the stage seeing Belichick and
Goodell have an exchange and uh I
tweeted up a little video I had and they
have long excuse with a lot of shoulder
patting and nodding and all that stuff
you know I understand what you had to do
to calm it really helped us out in the
long run getting for four weeks rest we
appreciated and now we can actually turn
Jimmy and good god knows what I'm there
for you I'm really a girl man I think
what Brady said to Goodell is can you
believe I almost lost my job at halftime
to Jimmy Garoppolo now I I turned out to
be the MVP Raj I'll see you at the press
conference where you hand me my MVP
award we'll play nice then I I have so
many freezing cold takes from happening
with you Matt McNish rival Garoppolo
it's just tough to see Tommy go out this
way it's unbelieving and I've lived here
all my life but I am still a god
and how absurd we are as a fanbase Media
Group the whole thing where there's a
bunch is deflategate over now it's dead
it's over we move forward we move
forward yes
how long national nightmare is over but
it could yeah and this was what I wrote
about Hadean I can't imagine how stomach
churning it must have been to the rest
of the country to watch that team that
everyone was looking to have its nut
stomped on national television for an
hour of football just reach the hand up
from under the grave and pull everybody
back down because don't you think that
most of the country was really rejoicing
and what was unfolding yes
yeah and hashtag column he's the MVP
again no I
feels like the accents getting a little
heavier there Tommy
I'm tired haven't gone to bed yet oh so
it starts to get a little more syrupy a
little uh a little more Bostonian yeah
yeah it's like when you could speak
better French after you have a beer to
m-19 shave eight years of French safe
trout or a blowy of us we're done now
yes yeah all right yeah gotta get on the
plane go home all right thanks for
having me thanks for the back fact that
I got you're welcome Tommy it's terrific
you were great okay thank you joy
hashtag Tommy current right we gave
every one of our guests in Houston a
backpack Dan Patrick show backpack so
that's what he was referring to he's a
knucklehead though the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
you